Hi, this is Thing, and I'm waiting to be the surprise guest on Smartless.
I'm quite sure what that means, Smartless.
But we're going to find out.
They're going to talk to me for an hour, so hopefully I can be Smartless with them.
Welcome to Smartless.
Oh, Will.
Will, you've been...
Did you sleep over at Thoreau's last night?
嗨，我是“小手”（Thing），我正等着作为惊喜嘉宾上《Smartless》播客呢。我其实不太清楚“Smartless”是什么意思，但我们马上就会知道了。他们要跟我聊一个小时，所以希望我也能和他们一样“大智若愚”（Smartless）。欢迎收听《Smartless》。哦，威尔。威尔，你刚刚……你昨晚是在梭罗（Thoreau）家过夜的吗？
I just realized.
I had an overshirt in the other room, and I just...
I was working out, and I was like, I was like,
I took a long-sleeve shirt out just to put it on,
and I was like, oh, shit, it's 9-30,
and I took a leak, and I got my water, and I got it in here.
I was like, as I logged in, as my Zoom came up,
I went, motherfucker, I'm not wearing.
我刚刚意识到。我在另一个房间里有一件外衣，我刚刚……我刚才在健身，然后我想，我想，我拿了一件长袖衬衫出来想穿上，然后我想，哦，靠，9点半了，我去尿了个尿，拿了我的水，然后我把它拿到了这儿。我想着，当我登录的时候，当我的Zoom弹出来的时候，我心想，他妈的，我没穿……
You're not wearing sleeves, and so Justin Thro's just,
he's just waking up.
Justin Throo, he's not allowed to wear a Liverpool football club.
I cut off a t-shirt.
He just had a baby.
He did.
Oh, my God.
你没穿袖子，所以贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）刚醒，贾斯汀·塞洛克斯，他不能穿利物浦足球俱乐部的衣服。我剪掉了一件T恤。他刚当爸爸。他确实当爸爸了。哦，天哪。
I saw a shot of him sleeping with his new baby on his chest.
But he wasn't at home sleeping.
I guess he was in the hospital or something.
But true to form, his tops off.
I know what you're going to say.
His tops off.
He might have been on an airplane.
Yeah, he can't.
我看到了一张他光着膀子和新出生的宝宝躺在胸口睡觉的照片。但他不是在家睡觉。我想他是在医院什么的。不过一如既往，他光着上身。我知道你要说什么。他光着上身。他可能在飞机上。对，他不能……
He likes to, he'll fly without a shirt on one of you, right?
Yeah, you know this, Sean, right?
When he flies, you know, he's on a plane.
He can't sleep.
He can't even say the word.
word.
Oh my God, it won't even
come out in your lips.
他喜欢，他会光着上身坐飞机，你们谁知道对吧？对，你知道的，肖恩，对吧？当他坐飞机时，你知道的，他在飞机上。他睡不着。他甚至说不出那个词。那个词。哦，天哪，它甚至没法从你的嘴唇里吐出来。
Justin can't sleep
with a shirt on. And so
if he's going to sleep on a plane,
if it's a night flight, he takes
his top off.
And
the flight attendant's got to wake him up and say
sir, you can't sleep.
贾斯汀穿着衬衫就睡不着。所以如果他要在飞机上睡觉，如果是夜航班，他就会脱掉上衣。空姐不得不把他叫醒说，先生，你不能睡……
I didn't know that. You can't have your shirt off on a plane.
He says, well, I can't sleep with a shirt on.
J.B. Although I do remember, do you remember years ago,
you, me, Tony Hale,
Eli and somebody else, maybe car or somebody from your team,
we flew back from London,
and we threw fingers for the thing that folded into the bed.
And then I didn't have a shirt on it.
我不知道这个。你不能在飞机上光着身子。他说，好吧，我穿衣服睡不着。J.B.，不过我确实记得，你还记得多年前吗？你、我、托尼·黑尔（Tony Hale）、伊莱（Eli）还有别的什么人，也许是卡尔（Carl）或者你团队里的某个人，我们从伦敦飞回来，我们用“剪刀石头布”（throw fingers）来决定谁睡能折叠成床的座位。然后我没穿上衣。
Remember, you're disgust.
That's disgusting.
You're like, you're not wearing your shirt.
You know what I do now?
It's hot.
You're in public.
When I go to sleep, I stick my shirt into my pants like that.
I stick my shirt so that when I roll around at night,
记得吗，你很嫌弃。太恶心了。你当时说，你没穿衬衫。你知道我现在怎么做吗？太热了。你在公共场所。当我睡觉时，我把衬衫塞进裤子里，就像这样。我把衬衫塞进去，这样当我晚上翻身时，
the shirt doesn't come up.
Why don't you get one of those little onesies snaps?
Hey, listen, to our listeners, anybody out there who's just looking for some, some...
Who's lonely and looking for some hot dude.
Just some hot stuff going on.
You don't want to tuck that shirt into your CPAP hose?
Sean, you should just do a sidecast.
Tuck it into your seatpap poses.
衬衫就不会跑上来。你怎么不买那种带按扣的连体婴儿衣呢？嘿，听着，对我们的听众说，任何正在寻找一些，一些……孤单并寻找性感帅哥的人。只想找点刺激的事。你不想把衬衫塞进你的持续正压通气（CPAP）呼吸机软管里吗？肖恩，你应该直接整个侧面播客（sidecast）。把它塞进你的CPAP软管里。
Just do a sidecast where you describe some of your routines for Sean after Doc, you know?
Don't threaten me.
Sean sent us a picture last night to J.B. and me after the show.
And again, it was the star of the photo, again,
was a heaping plate of spaghetti.
Uh-huh.
And then the supporting cast was on the same plate.
Swedish fish.
就整个侧面播客，描述一下你对肖恩的一些生活习惯，在Doc之后，你知道的？别威胁我。肖恩昨晚发了一张照片给J.B.和我，在节目结束后。而且，照片的主角又一次是一大盘意面。嗯哼。然后配角也在同一个盘子里。瑞典鱼软糖（Swedish fish）。
Yeah, absolutely.
A big fat bag of them.
And I said one other one.
And he's having more now.
You sprinkle the fish on the pasta.
Jamie, you suggest that he mix it in.
But there was no like, ha-ha or anything.
Jason just wrote,
对，绝对的。一大包呢。我还说了另一个。他现在还要吃。你把鱼软糖撒在意面上。杰米，你建议他把它拌进去。但没有什么“哈哈”或者别的什么。杰森只是写道：
put the fish in the spaghetti.
And you thought it was a good idea.
I did think it was a good idea.
It was great.
You know what I did last week?
What I do is every single day
I wear my slippers to the theater
because I know right away
把鱼软糖放进意面里。而你觉得这是个好主意。我确实觉得这是个好主意。太棒了。你知道我上周做了什么吗？我做的是，每天我都穿着拖鞋去剧院，因为我知道马上
I'm just coming home and going right to bed.
Hold on.
You're shuffling down some New York Street and slippers
just blending in.
Well, I get out of the car
straight to the stage door.
But the other day, the traffic was so bad
我就要回家直接睡觉了。等等。等等。你穿着拖鞋在纽约的街道上拖沓前行，就这么混在人群里。好吧，我下车直接去舞台门。但前几天，交通太糟糕了
I had to get out and run.
So I'm running down the street
with my hair still wet from the shower
in slippers with like a ratty t-shirt.
I looked like a...
Like a New York resident.
I'm sorry, real quick.
How do you think you look now?
我不得不下车跑过去。所以我穿着拖鞋在街上跑，头发还湿漉漉的，是从浴室出来的那种，还穿着一件破烂的T恤。我看起来像个……像个地道的纽约居民。不好意思，说真的。你觉得你现在看起来怎么样？
Wait, how come you're wearing slippers
out of the car and into the theater?
Oh, this is way to go, way to go, Sean.
Here we go.
Do you not like shoes?
No, well, it's inconvenient to wear shoes.
Well, I'm not going anywhere after the show.
I'm just going home so I can just keep them on.
等等，你怎么穿着拖鞋下车去剧院？哦，这可真行，真有你的，肖恩。来吧。你不喜欢鞋子吗？不，好吧，穿鞋很不方便。好吧，演出结束后我又不去哪儿。我只是回家，所以我可以一直穿着它们。
And you throw them straight into the incinerator or...
When I'm done, yeah.
I've gone to dinner with Sean at J.R.
And I had slippers on.
And he shows up and he's wearing slippers, J.B.
Why?
But why?
Are you taught, just that you don't want to deal with laces and things?
然后你把它们直接扔进焚化炉或者……当我用完的时候，对。我和肖恩在J.R.吃过晚饭。我当时穿着拖鞋。然后他出现了，他也穿着拖鞋，J.B.。为什么？但为什么呢？你受到的教育是，你只是不想对付鞋带和那些东西吗？
Yeah, yeah.
I just want to go to the theater.
Hold it.
There are a thousand options for men.
Velcro, New Balance.
I think you're at that place.
对，对。我只想去剧院。等等。等等。等等。男人的选择有上千种。魔术贴，新百伦（New Balance）。我觉得你到了那个年纪，
That are laceless shoes that you can be proud of.
That if you do need to run down a street, they will work.
Like fans or loafers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or boots.
I know, I got to start getting, though.
Boots shoes.
Or what shoes?
有那种你可以引以为傲的无鞋带鞋。如果你真的需要在大街上跑，它们也能派上用场。比如Vans或者乐福鞋。对，对，对。或者靴子。我知道，我得开始穿了。船鞋（Boot shoes）。或者什么鞋？
Boat shoes.
Crocs even would be a lesser offense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, you think about it.
I love my hugs.
Crocs are an interesting.
Where do we land on crocs?
船鞋（Boat shoes）。甚至连洞洞鞋（Crocs）冒犯程度都算轻的。对，对，对。好吧，你想想。我爱我的UGG。洞洞鞋是一个有趣的……我们对洞洞鞋怎么看？
Have we been there?
I think the jury's still out.
There's a long deliberation, yeah.
It's like jazz.
We're still out.
Is it cool to like it or cool to not?
I won't take a position on jazz yet.
Yeah, well, you don't want to go down the drain
我们讨论过这个吗？我觉得还在讨论中。这是一场旷日持久的审议，对。就像爵士乐。我们还在讨论。喜欢它算酷还是讨厌它算酷？我暂时对爵士乐不予置评。对，好吧，你可不想像我们最近某位知名演员一样，
like one of our famous actors lately.
I mean, and by the way.
I'm just saying in terms of whether it's for me or not, I'm saying.
Oh, yeah.
Well, you know what?
I think it is, it's something that I, you know,
Ken Burns got me really into baseball because of his documentary on baseball.
This is 30-some years ago.
掉进沟里去。我的意思是，顺便说一句。我只是说关于它是不是适合我，我是说。哦，对。好吧，你知道吗？我觉得这是，这是我，你知道的，肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）因为他的棒球纪录片让我对棒球非常着迷。这是三十多年前的事了。
I've got to watch that.
And he's got one on jazz that I'm waiting to open up and climb into because I think I'd be addicted to it.
Oh, yeah.
Once I get his.
I'm not calling into question the incredible musicianship or any of that.
I mean, in terms of personal days.
Wait, you guys, there's a new U.S.
phone documentary that just came out.
我得去看看那个。他还有一部关于爵士乐的纪录片，我正等着翻开它并钻研进去，因为我觉得我会对它上瘾。哦，对。一旦我看了他的……我并不是在质疑那些不可思议的音乐造诣或诸如此类的事情。我是说就个人喜好而言。等等，伙计们，有一部新的美国电话（U.S. phone）纪录片刚刚上映。
Really?
You got to see it.
Hang on.
I got to take the tinfoil off my TV,
but I definitely want to watch it.
This is not the age of disclosure?
Yeah, no, it's the same.
No, no, it's...
真的吗？你得去看看。等等。我得把电视上的锡纸撕下来，但我绝对想看这个。这不是信息披露时代（Age of disclosure）吗？对，不，是一样的。不，不，那是……
Age of disclosure is incredible.
Who is the guy?
Yeah, it's the guy...
Shoot, I can't remember his name.
I'll find it by the time...
You can text it to me when we talk later.
Okay, okay.
Now, you guys have talked about a couple of things
信息披露时代太不可思议了。那家伙是谁？对，就是那个家伙……该死，我想不起他名字了。等我们聊完的时候我能找到……到时候你可以发短信告诉我。好的，好的。现在，你们俩聊了几个
that our guest can really chime in on
and straighten out for us.
One is how to keep the voice
healthy on stage and the other is jazz.
Wow.
Oh, mama.
Yeah.
Dudes,
我们的嘉宾真的可以插上话并给我们理清头绪的事情。一个是如何在舞台上保持嗓子健康，另一个是爵士乐。哇哦。哦，天哪。对，
today, for your listening pleasure,
I offer you a man with just a dash of talent
and a tiny sprinkle of accomplishments.
He's an actor and a musician.
He has a Golden Globe,
an Emmy, four Academy Award nominations.
He's received a Kennedy Center honor
and a CBE of the British Empire.
伙计们，今天为了你们的听觉享受，我给你们请来了一位只有一点点天赋和一点点成就的男士。他是一位演员和音乐家。他拥有金球奖、艾美奖、四项奥斯卡奖提名。他获得了肯尼迪中心荣誉奖和不列颠帝国司令勋章（CBE）。
As a musician, he's received,
17 Grammy Awards.
He sold 100 million records.
What's what?
And has been inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
He's been doing what he does in a league of his own
and consistently setting the mark for what is relevant
and cool since the year I was born, literally.
作为一名音乐家，他获得了17项格莱美奖。他卖出了1亿张唱片。什么什么？并且入选了摇滚名人堂。他一直以独一无二的方式做着他所做的事，并且字面意思上自我出生那年起就不断为什么是相关和酷设定标准。
He's one of my heroes and I'm incredibly excited
to welcome him here today.
Fellas, here's the one and only, Sting.
Oh, way.
Oh, man.
Good morning, gentlemen.
This is a big guy.
So cool.
他是我的偶像之一，我非常激动能在这里欢迎他。伙计们，这位是独一无二的，斯汀（Sting）。哦，哇。哦，天哪。早安，各位先生。这家伙来头不小。太酷了。
Wow.
I apologize for you, the elongated coffee chat up front.
Thank you for staying with us.
It's riveting, I know.
But as you see, this is our only time to really communicate.
And so we steal a little bit of time from our guests and we chit-chat.
But now we've got talking points to talk about.
Let's start with vocal health on stage.
哇。我为我们前面冗长的咖啡闲聊向你们道歉。谢谢你们一直陪着我们。我知道这很引人入胜。但如你们所见，这是我们真正交流的唯一时间。所以我们从嘉宾那里偷了一点时间来闲聊。但现在我们有话题要聊了。让我们从舞台上的声乐健康开始吧。
Are gummy bears and pasta a part of your vocal health at all?
Is that your key?
Definitely not.
No.
You know, it is a muscle.
So you have to treat it with the respect you would treat a muscle if you were a footballer or a runner.
And do exercises, yeah.
You have to stretch.
小熊软糖和意面是你们声乐健康的一部分吗？那是你们的秘诀吗？绝对不是。不。你知道，它是一块肌肉。所以你必须以对待肌肉的尊重来对待它，就像你是一个足球运动员或跑步者一样。要做练习，对。你必须拉伸。
You have to sing before you go on.
Do, yeah, exercise.
What's your favorite?
What's your go-to set of push-ups for your vocal ports?
For my voice, I think you start gently with lip trills.
Yeah.
Fifth?
上台前你必须唱歌。要做，对，锻炼。你最喜欢的是什么？你针对声带的常规俯卧撑是什么？对于我的声音，我想你得从温和的唇颤音开始。对。对。五度音阶？
Yeah.
And that loosens everything up.
And then you get fuller and fuller.
Don't leave your best notes in the dressing room, though.
That's the sequence.
Ah.
Yeah.
对。这样可以放松所有部位。对。然后声音变得越来越饱满。不过，别把你的最佳音符留在化妆室里。这就是顺序。啊。对。
Right.
Do you do all the, do you do all the, wah, wow, wow, wow.
I do we.
Wow, wow, wow.
Yeah, very good.
Yeah.
对吧？你做不做所有的，你做不做所有的，哇，哇，哇，哇。我做“we”。哇，哇，哇。对，非常好。对。对。对。
You have to.
And you taught yourself, you taught yourself early on to sing, yes?
Or did you, did you take, did you ever take any formal lessons?
I sold newspapers as a child on the street corner
so my first singing job was to sell the Evenin Chronicle
in my town
and I would sing
对。你必须这样做。你很早就自学唱歌了，对吧？或者你，你上过，你上过任何正规的声乐课吗？我小时候在街角卖报纸，所以我的第一份唱歌的工作就是在我镇上卖《晚间纪事报》（Evening Chronicle），我会唱……
Evening Chronicle
Yeah
Really?
That would get some attention
And people would come over because it was loud
And you'd be like, hey, you want to buy a paper?
Of course, yeah
I'd stand outside the shipyard where I was born next to a shipyard
《晚间纪事报》！对，真的吗？这会吸引一些注意，人们会走过来，因为声音很大。然后你会说，嘿，想买份报纸吗？当然，对，我会站在我出生的造船厂外面，挨着造船厂，
and I'd sell the evening paper to the shipyard workers as they came out.
Do it again?
What are the words?
Evening, chronic.
It does sound oddly like Sean.
Eveninging.
See?
我会把晚报卖给走出来的造船厂工人。再来一次？歌词是什么？再来一次？《晚间纪事报》。听起来确实有点像肖恩。晚间……看？
Yeah, there it is.
That's a good warm-up.
And then also, Sting, the, now, you know, I do a lot of incredibly in-depth research.
So on Wikipedia.
You have access to Google.
Is that what you mean?
Yeah.
On Wikipedia.
对，就是这样。这是一个很好的热身。然后还有，斯汀，现在，你知道的，我做了很多非常深入的研究。所以在维基百科上……你能够访问谷歌。你是这个意思吗？对，在维基百科上。
they say, is this true,
that you, a friend
of your father, I think, left
behind a guitar and a Spanish
guitar? And that
that is what sort of sparked
the interest in music, and you were
playing around with that? Partially true?
他们说，这是真的吗？你，你父亲的一位朋友，我想，留下一把吉他，一把西班牙吉他？然后这就某种程度上激发了你对音乐的兴趣，你在摆弄那个？部分属实？
Well, as a kid,
when I eight years old,
my, I called him my uncle John.
Everybody was your uncle in my street.
He emigrated to Canada.
Yes. Good choice.
And he couldn't take his guitar. So he
We left it to the family, and I recognize that thing as a friend for life.
好吧，作为孩子，当我八岁的时候，我，我叫他约翰叔叔。我那条街上的每个人都是你的叔叔。他移民去了加拿大。是的。明智的选择。他没法带走他的吉他，所以他……我们把它留给了家里，我把那东西视为终生的朋友。
I also recognize that as some kind of escape mechanism.
I thought, I'm going to escape with this thing.
It was a vague idea, but I did not want to work in that shipyard where everybody else worked.
So I thought the guitar is maybe my passage out of, my passport out of here.
And I sat in the corner, I didn't speak to anyone for six months,
learned to play it.
I saved up for the string that was missing.
Really?
我也认为那是一种某种逃避机制。我想，我要带着这东西逃跑。那是一个模糊的想法，但我不想去那个所有人都在工作的造船厂上班。所以我想吉他也许是我离开这里的通道，是我离开这里的护照。我坐在角落里，六个月没跟任何人说话，学会了弹奏它。我攒钱买断了缺的那根弦。真的吗？
And I could play pretty quickly.
Totally self-taught.
You just sort of figured out
the combination of little pressing with the fingers
gives you a different chord.
Or was there any help?
I had a very good musical ear.
My mom was a piano player.
而且我很快就学会弹了。完全自学。你只是摸索出用手指按压不同组合就能发出不同和弦吗？还是有什么帮助？我有着非常好的音乐耳朵。我妈妈是个钢琴演奏者。
So she sort of listened to me and said,
you have a good ear, son.
You should learn music.
So she sent me down the street
to an old music teacher, retired.
and he taught me music.
But I have to walk down my high street with a guitar in a plastic bag.
And you could not go unmolested if you were carrying a guitar down my high street.
所以她有点像听着我说，你有一双好耳朵，孩子。你应该学习音乐。所以她把我打发到街下去找一位退休的老音乐老师。他教我音乐。但我得拎着装在塑料袋里的吉他走过我们镇上的商业街。如果你拎着吉他走过我的商业街，你是不可能安然无恙的。
You should have worn slippers.
They would have stayed away from you.
That's Sean's safety strategy.
I never wear slippers.
Wow, wait.
So, Sting, whereabouts is this in England?
Okay, I come from the northeast coast of England.
And between the city of Newcastle and the North Sea
你当时应该穿双拖鞋。他们就会离你远远的了。那是肖恩的安全策略。我从来不穿拖鞋。哇，等等。所以，斯汀，这大概是英国的什么地方？好吧，我来自英格兰东北海岸。在纽卡斯尔市和北海之间，
is a town called Walls End where it was a big shipyard.
That was the only source of employment in the town.
And it was quite a surreal industrial environment.
Literally, I lived next door to this place.
My street would be, the sun would be blotted out by the ship,
the hull of a ship.
I'd watch thousands of men walk to work every morning
and think, is that what I have to do?
有一个叫“墙端”（Walls End）的小镇，那里有一个大造船厂。那是镇上唯一的就业来源。那是一个相当超现实的工业环境。真的，我就住在紧挨着这个地方的隔壁。我的街道会被船，一艘船的船体把阳光完全遮挡住。我每天早晨看着成千上万的工人步行去上班，心想，这就是我以后要做的事吗？
And now you've written, we're going to get to this, but you've not recently written,
but you are doing another tour of and grander yet of the last ship.
Yes?
Tell us about it.
Well, I've been writing it my whole life in a way.
You know, I described a surreal industrial environment, which I did not appreciate at the time.
But in hindsight, you know, once I had left and I had an international career and success,
I realized that I was gifted with something that was quite precious.
而现在你写了——我们待会儿会聊到这个，但你最近没有写，而是正在进行另一场规模更大、更宏大的《最后一艘船》（The Last Ship）巡演。是的？给我们讲讲吧。嗯，某种程度上我一生都在写它。你知道的，我描述了一个超现实的工业环境，当时我并没有意识到它的价值。但事后回想起来，你知道的，一旦我离开了，有了国际职业生涯和成功，我意识到我被赋予了非常珍贵的东西。
I mean, the profound symbolism of giant ships,
a river going by the end of the house,
the sea, a church tower.
These were very powerful symbols for a budding songwriter,
a budding writer, a budding artist.
And I realized that I needed to tell the story of my community,
the community that made me who I am.
It gave me a sense of identity,
我是说，巨轮的深远象征意义，流淌在房屋尽头的河流，大海，教堂钟楼。对于一个崭露头角的词曲作者、一个崭露头角的作家、一个崭露头角的艺术家来说，这些都是非常强大的象征。我意识到我需要讲述我的社区的故事，那个塑造了今天的我的社区。它给了我身份认同感，
a work ethic, an engine to escape from it.
But nonetheless, I needed to pay a debt back, if you like,
to the people who brought me up and say thank you.
So then how did you...
So how did you come from there, from this place,
in the northeast of England,
and sort of
not self-taught,
一种职业道德，以及从中逃离的动力。但尽管如此，如果你愿意的话，我需要向把我养大的人们偿还债务，并说一声谢谢。那么你是如何……你是如何从那里，从这个地方，从英格兰东北部，来到这里的，不是自学成才，
but you obviously had this inclination
and you had the help from this music teacher
and then how did you
how did you form the police?
How did that first happen?
I'm so interested.
I'm such a, I got to say, I'm freaking out a little bit.
Yeah, me too.
但你显然有这种倾向，并且得到了这位音乐老师的帮助，然后你是如何，你是如何组建警察乐队（The Police）的？这一切最初是怎么发生的？我太感兴趣了。我太……我得说，我有点吓坏了。对，我也是。
I'm such a massive fan of you.
Me too.
I did a lot of stuff before I got a job on the police.
I had a real job before I was a celebrity.
I was a school teacher.
No way.
I taught in a mining village.
I taught 11-year-olds.
我是你的超级大粉丝。我也是。在加入警察乐队之前，我做过很多事情。在成为名人之前，我有过一份真正的工作。我是一名学校老师。不会吧。我在一个矿工村教书。我教11岁的孩子。
Wow.
Soccer, music, English, math.
And then I realized that if I didn't leave this teaching job,
I would be stuck there forever.
So I told the headmistress, she was a nun.
I said, I'm leaving at the end of term.
And she said, well, you'll lose your pension.
哇。足球、音乐、英语、数学。哇。然后我意识到，如果我不离开这份教书的工作，我就会永远被困在那里。所以我告诉女校长，她是个修女。我说，学期结束我就辞职。她说，好吧，你会失去你的退休金。
And she was right.
I did lose my pension.
You were probably 30 years away from your pension, at least, right?
Yeah, it was important then, though.
But I decided, no, I would go to London.
So I had one phone number.
I was also a dad.
I just recently had a kid who was married.
她说得对。我确实失去了我的退休金。你距离退休金可能还有30年，至少吧？对，不过当时这很重要。但我决定，不，我要去伦敦。所以我只有一个电话号码。我还是个爸爸。我最近刚有了一个孩子，已经结婚了。
I had a car and a dog.
I paid tax.
I voted.
So I was a grown-up before I became a coseted celebrity.
So I always say that.
That's so important for me.
It gives me my balance.
If I have any balance, it's because of that.
我有一辆车和一条狗。我交税。我投票。所以在成为一个被娇惯的名人之前，我已经是个成年人了。所以我总是这么说。这对我很重要。它给了我平衡感。如果我有什么平衡感的话，那就是因为它。
But you were armed with this incredible intellect
and this environment, this upbringing of,
I mean, it sounds incredibly, you know, cinematic A,
but these elements that, to me, sort of lend themselves
to metaphor,
and issues of sort of existentialism and whatnot.
Like you were able to match your intellect to your upbringing
and write these songs for the rest of your life.
但你拥有这种难以置信的才华和这种环境，这种成长经历——我的意思是，听起来非常，你知道的，A，很有电影感，但这些元素对我来说，某种程度上本身就带有隐喻色彩，以及存在主义之类的问题。就像你能够将你的才华与你的成长经历相匹配，并在余生中创作这些歌曲。
Is that what kind of do you find that it all culminates
into this great place with the last ship?
Well, J.B., I'll sort of dove on that too,
which is so many musicians or artists that we talk to
have come out, you know, start doing it very young,
maybe start in a band when they're 19,
and they haven't had the things that you just described.
All these experience, these rich experiences
你觉得这一切最终都汇聚到了《最后一艘船》这个伟大的地方吗？嗯，J.B.，我也想顺着这个思路说下去，那就是我们交谈过的许多音乐家或艺术家，他们出道时都非常年轻，可能19岁就开始组乐队了，他们没有经历过你刚才描述的那些事情。所有这些经历，这些丰富的人生经历——
of being a dad, of having a job,
of paying taxes, of voting, all that kind of stuff.
And then they go into this artistic life,
and they don't have, you seem to have, like, again,
kind of, J.B., what you were saying,
drawing on all these real life experiences.
Yeah, and your lyrics always have been.
Yeah.
当爸爸、拥有一份工作、交税、投票，所有这些乱七八糟的事。然后他们进入了这种艺术生活，却缺乏——你似乎拥有，就像，再次回到J.B.刚才说的，汲取所有这些真实的生活经历。对，而且你的歌词一直都是这样。对。
You know, they're far from silly.
They're always about something
Some of them are silly, Jason
No, I don't know
Let's do do do da-da-da
I suppose
Well, they're the least silly
They're the least silly
你知道的，它们一点也不愚蠢。它们总是关于某种东西的。有些歌词挺傻的，杰森。不，我不知道。咱们说说“do-do-do da-da-da”吧。我想……好吧，它们是最不傻的。它们是最不傻的。
I mean I was making a point there
About nonsense songs
Yeah yeah yeah
Do I diddy didi da do run run
Yeah yeah
Hey nonny noni no from Shakespeare
I mean
Obla di obla da
我的意思是，我在那里表达一个观点，关于无意义的歌词。对，对，对。Do I diddy didi da do run run。对，对。莎士比亚笔下的“Hey nonny noni no”。我的意思是，《Obla di obla da》。
It's a tradition
Well sorry just a side notes thing
I know we've asked you five questions
here and you haven't
But one of your more famous sort of one word lyrics,
and I wanted to hear your thoughts on this, of course,
is in the dire straight song,
is when you came on you saying,
这是一个传统。好吧，抱歉，顺便提一下，斯汀，我知道我们已经向你提出了五个问题，而你还没……但你更著名的一句单字歌词之一，我想听听你对此的想法，当然是在恐怖海峡乐队（Dire Straits）的那首歌里，当你出场时唱道：
I want my MTV.
All right, launched the whole thing.
I mean, launched an entire thing.
But anyway.
But, yeah, so then, so yeah, so picking one of those questions,
still continuing last ship,
have you found that this is, and you're nowhere near done,
but that this is a really interesting project for you
“我想要我的MTV”。好吧，开启了整个事情。我的意思是，开启了整个时代。但不管怎样。但是，是的，所以，是的，挑选其中一个问题，继续讨论《最后一艘船》，你是否发现这是一个，虽然你远未结束，但这对你来说是一个非常有趣的项目，
to now revisit and continue to talk about,
because I think there's some new songs in it,
talk about where you came from
and marrying your experience, your intellect,
and all of that into how you started.
You know, it's a deeply emotional play for me.
My parents, who died 40 years ago,
are on stage with me every night.
让你现在重新审视并继续讨论，因为我认为里面有一些新歌，讨论你来自哪里，并将你的经历、你的才华以及所有这些融合到你的起步中。你知道，对我的父母来说，这是一部情感极为深厚的戏剧。40年前去世的父母每晚都和我同台演出。
There's something,
there's kind of spiritual connection I have.
with the people I've lost.
And my brother came to see the play in Amsterdam the other day.
And he was a wreck.
He cried from the beginning to the end.
In a good way.
It was cathartic for him.
有些东西，我与失去的人之间有一种精神上的联系。我的兄弟前几天在阿姆斯特丹看了这部剧。他彻底崩溃了。他从头哭到尾。是那种好的方面。这对他来说是一种宣泄。
But he knows exactly what I'm singing about
and the community that we come from.
So it's a very emotional play.
And I'm going to be doing it at the Metropolitan Opera House in New York City.
I mean, it's such an amazing dream.
I'm going to come see that. I'm going to be in town. I'm going to come see that.
Please do.
Yeah. I'm very, very excited about it.
但他完全懂我在唱什么，也懂我们出身的社区。所以这是一部非常感人的剧。我将把它带到纽约市的大都会歌剧院（Metropolitan Opera House）上演。我的意思是，这真的是个amazing的梦想。我会去看那场。我到时候正好在城里。我会去看的。请务必来。对。我对此感到非常、非常兴奋。
And what about it for you said to your, you said to yourself, well, I'm going to write a musical about this.
And there's going to be performance in addition to music and lyrics and stuff, as opposed to I want to write an album about this subject.
I think I was going through a period of, I call it writer's block, but that's a little bit dramatic.
but just wondering what do you write about?
You know, you're in your 40s.
You don't want to write about your Chevrolet or your girlfriend.
You know, it's just, you're beyond that.
So I went back to my past.
至于你对自己说，“嗯，我要写一部关于这个的音乐剧。除了音乐和歌词之类的东西之外，还会有表演”，而不是“我想写一张关于这个主题的专辑”，你当时是怎么想的？我想我当时正经历一段时期，我称之为“作家之 BLOCK（灵感枯竭）”，但这么说有点戏剧化了。不过就是纳闷：你该写什么呢？你知道的，你四十多岁了。你不想写你的雪佛兰或者你的女朋友。你知道的，你已经超越那个阶段了。所以我回到了我的过去。
Went back to the town I was brought up in
and started to sing songs about people I knew.
And that freed me up.
Instead of navel-gazing into my own psyche,
I would try and, you know, see the world through somebody else's eyes.
somebody I knew.
And that really freed up the songwriting.
And these songs came out of me like projectile vomiting
回到了我长大的那个小镇，开始唱关于我认识的人的歌。这让我解放了。与其陷入我自己的心灵深处进行内省，我不如试着，你知道的，通过别人的眼睛去看世界，一个我认识的人。这真的解放了我的歌曲创作。这些歌就像喷射式呕吐一样从我体内涌出，
as if they'd been stored up there for a long, long time.
It was a very quick process.
Is it because the subject matter or the thematics of it
are particularly more relevant and resonant today in today's society?
Oh, I think there are certainly relevance to today.
It's about a community under threat.
from economic forces that they have no control over.
Economics are saying,
就好像它们在里面储藏了很长、很长的时间一样。这是一个非常快速的过程。是因为它的题材或主题在当今社会更加具有现实意义和共鸣吗？哦，我认为它们对今天绝对有现实意义。这是一个处于威胁之中的社区。受到他们无法控制的经济力量的威胁。经济学在说，
well, the job you do, making ships is now irrelevant,
and you are expendable.
And, of course, all of us are facing that right now with AI.
All of us can be replaced by a robot,
so they think.
I have opinions about that.
But we are under threat.
Yeah.
好吧，你们做的工作，造船现在已经过时了，你们是可有可无的。当然，我们所有人现在都在面对人工智能（AI）带来的这种威胁。我们所有人都可能被机器人取代，他们是这么认为的。对此我有我自己的看法。但我们正处于威胁之中。对。
I remember I watched that documentary about...
Sunderland until I die, which is not far, I guess, from you.
That was...
Very close.
You're a Newcastle fan, though, yes?
I support the other team.
You support Newcastle.
It's a good squad.
我记得我看过那部纪录片……《直至死亡支持桑德兰》（Sunderland 'Til I Die），离你那儿不远，我想。那是……非常近。不过你是纽卡斯尔（Newcastle）球迷，对吧？我支持另一支球队。你支持纽卡斯尔。那是一支好球队。
I'm a Liverpool.
I'm a Liverpool supporter.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
I did want to get more into the lyrics
because you've always...
Well, first of all, another thing is
are you...
我是利物浦球迷。我是利物浦球迷。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。我确实想更多地了解歌词，因为你一直……好吧，首先，另一个问题是：
Do you write music first? Do you write lyrics first?
Do you write lyrics first?
Is it a mixture of the two?
Because so many of your lyrics, I mean, so many of your songs,
you know, the lyrics are so, I don't know,
message in a bottle, for instance, like a song like that,
which is so dense lyrically and is such an incredible...
They're satisfying on their own,
你是先写音乐吗？你先写歌词吗？你是先写歌词吗？还是两者的混合？因为你的很多歌词——我的意思是，你的许多歌曲，你知道的，歌词是如此，我不知道，比如《瓶中信》（Message in a Bottle），像这样的一首歌，在歌词上如此丰富，而且是一首如此不可思议的……它们本身就很满足，
don't even need them.
Yeah, it's such a great message and so resonant.
You know, there's no one method to write a song.
You can start with a lyric, you can start with a lyric,
a riff or a series of chords or a melody that suddenly floats into your head.
But I have to remind myself every time I want to write a song that all of them,
even the most successful ones, began as a tiny kernel of an idea.
Just something that intrigued me, a novelty, an interval,
甚至不需要音乐。对，这是一个如此伟大的信息，而且如此富有共鸣。你知道的，写歌没有单一的方法。你可以从歌词开始，你可以从一句歌词、一个riff（特色乐句）、一连串和弦或突然浮现在脑海的旋律开始。但我每次想写歌时都必须提醒自己，所有的歌，甚至是最成功的那些，最初都只是一个极小的灵感内核。只是一些激起我兴趣的东西、一个新奇的事物、一个音程、
a flattened fifth or something very tiny.
and then I built on it bit by bit.
And they weren't masterpieces until you did a lot of work on them.
Yeah.
Does that...
Yeah, but that's not a message on a bottle and I'm thinking about it.
For me, that's always been one of those songs that really sort of captures that...
The spirit of loneliness, especially at the end when you sort of say,
一个降五度或者非常微小的东西。然后我一点一点地在此基础上构建。在付出大量心血之前，它们可算不上杰作。对。这……对，但那不是《瓶中信》，我正在想这个。对我来说，那首歌一直是真正捕捉到那种……孤独精神的歌曲之一，尤其是当你在结尾处唱到时，
you know, he talks about sending it out and then woke up this morning,
can't believe what I saw.
Yeah.
100 billion bottles wash up on the shore.
and I always loved the line,
seems I'm not alone at being alone.
It's just like that always, I mean,
it's as impactful to me today
你知道的，他谈到把信寄出去，然后“今天早上醒来，简直不敢相信我看到的”。对。“数以亿计的瓶子被冲上岸”。我一直很喜欢那句词：“看来孤独的不止我一个”。这就像那样总是——我的意思是，它对今天的我和我第一次听到时一样具有震撼力。我想知道你是否还记得写这首歌时的情景，以及写这样一首歌时你身在何处。我当时住在贝斯沃特（Bayswater），在一间地下室公寓里，那可不是伦敦环境优美的好地方。我写了那个吉他riff，《瓶中信》的那个东西，
as the first time I heard it.
And I wonder if you remember writing that
and where you were at when you wrote a song like that.
I was living in base water,
in a basement flat,
not a terribly salubrious part of London.
And I wrote that guitar riff,
the message in a bottle thing,
然后我在想，这是关于什么的？这是什么？我当时正处于情绪低谷。我想，我觉得自己像个遭遇海难的人。我是个流落荒岛的孤岛余生者。因为我当时并不成功。我一直在为谋生苦苦挣扎。我带着梦想来到伦敦，
And I'm thinking, what is this about?
What is it?
And I was feeling at a low ebb.
I'm thinking, I feel like I'm shipwrecked.
And I'm a castaway here.
Because I wasn't successful at the time.
I was struggling to make a living.
I'd gone to London with a dream,
而这个梦想并没有立即实现。所以这是那个时期的产物咯。我当时只能对狗唱歌。它偶尔会摇一下尾巴，但仅此而已。那是得到的唯一回应。当你谈到不管什么歌，
and it wasn't being realized immediately.
So this was from that period then.
And I'd only be singing it to the dog.
who would occasionally wag a tail
but that was it.
That was the only response I got.
When you say that all these,
no matter what the song is,
总是从一个小小的内核开始时，这是否会让你陷入这样一种境地：比如，你是否曾经因为害怕错过可能路过的小内核而无法放松？只是在街上走着，进行某种观察，
it always starts with just a little kernel,
does that then ever put you in a place of,
like, are you ever able to relax for fear of missing a little kernel
that might come by?
Just walking down the street,
making some sort of observation.
or hearing something somebody might say
or thinking of a little bit of a tune,
或者听到某人说的某句话，或者想到一个小曲调，你是否能够直接关掉雷达？我认为保留一个笔记本很重要，这样你就不会在脑海中带着旋律醒来。你有一个很小的笔记本，还是现在用iPhone？好吧，对，我用iPhone的备忘录。你做梦会梦到旋律吗？我脑子里会带着旋律醒来。
are you ever able to just turn off the radar?
It's important to keep a notebook, I think,
so you can't wake up with a melody in your head.
Do you have a little tiny notebook,
or do you use your iPhone now?
Well, yeah, notes on my iPhone.
Do you ever dream melodies?
I wake up with melodies in my head
我有时也会，但我太懒了，什么都不做。那通常是《本尼·希尔》（Benny Hill）的主题曲吗？当你带着旋律醒来时你该怎么办？你怎么记住它？你会把它哼进类似语音备忘录的东西里吗？我应该那么做，对。如果我醒来时脑子里有旋律，我就再也睡不着了。
I do too sometimes
but I'm too lazy to do anything about it
Is it usually the melody from Benny Hill
What do you do when you wake up with a melody
How do you remember? Do you hum it into like voice notes?
I should do that, yeah
I wouldn't get back to sleep
If I wake up with a melody I will not be able to sleep
我会下楼坐在吉他旁边说，好吧，回到……当我第一次去伦敦时，你还是一名老师。然后我总是很好奇，你是怎么——你参观过伦敦，你看到了大都市，它启发了你？就像你是怎么，是什么驱使你心想：你知道吗？我必须去伦敦追求这个。在我的家乡根本没有办法做我想做的事。
I go down and sit with a guitar and say okay
Go back to
I'm going to London for the first time when you were a teacher.
And then I'm always fascinated with like, how did you, had you visited London,
you saw the big city and it inspired you?
Like, how did you, what drove you to think, you know what?
I have to go to London and pursue this.
There was no way to do what I wanted to do in my town.
那里根本没有那种模板。而你心知肚明。你必须去伦敦。对，就是这样。对。所以，你知道的，我去试镜，为了唱歌
There was no template for that at all.
And you knew that.
You had to go to London.
Yeah, that was it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so, you know, I auditioned for, to sing.
in cocktail bars
在鸡尾酒吧里，他们会说，哦，我们要你唱公告牌前40名热门歌曲。我说，好吧，我一首前40名的歌都不会，但我有一首我自己的歌。然后我会唱《她施的每个魔法都如此神奇》（Every Little Thing She Does Is Magic），那个家伙就会说，嗯，这可不是热门单曲，对吧？我说，好吧，暂时还不是。如果他现在能看到你……
and they'd say
well we want you to do top 40 hits
I said well I don't know any top 40 hits
but I've got a song of my own and I'd sing
every little thing she does is magic
and the guy would say well it's not a hit as it
I said well not yet
if he could see you now
我没得到那份工作。哇，太惊人了。太惊人了。既然你是从吉他开始的，什么时候过渡到贝斯的？仅仅是因为那个家伙——我忘了和你一起开始的那家伙的名字了，斯图尔特（Stewart），后来安迪（Andy）取代了他？是因为他想弹吉他，所以你转行弹贝斯了吗？不，我认为这是一个非常、非常明智的选择。
I didn't get that job
wow that's amazing that's amazing
since you started on the guitar
when was the transition to bass
Was that simply because the guy, I forget his name who you started with,
with Stewart that Andy later replaced?
Was it because he wanted to play guitar and you pivoted over the bass?
No, I think it's a very, very astute choice to make.
如果你想成为一名乐队队长，因为我唱最高音，因为我弹最低音，乐队的其他成员实际上必须在我的乐队里、在我的带宽内运作。啊。作为一名贝斯手，你可以非常、非常深刻地改变和声。
If you want to be a band leader, because I sing the top line
and because I play the bottom line,
the rest of the band has to operate literally within my band,
my bandwidth.
Ah.
And as a bass player,
you can change the harmony
very, very profoundly.
钢琴手或吉他手可能在弹C和弦。如果我在下面弹一个G，我就彻底改变了和声。所以我掌握着控制权。
The piano player
or the guitarist
can be playing a C chord.
If I play a G
below that,
I've completely altered
the harmony.
So I'm in control.
这是一种非常微妙的控制方式。非常深奥。哦，哇。我很想……164或者164，或者565或者一个和弦，随便什么都行。
It's a very subtle way
of controlling.
It's very profound.
Oh, wow.
I'd love to...
164 or 164 or 565
or one chord,
whatever it is.
我认为转位（Inversions）是我音乐的核心。我喜欢这样。不是“变态（perversions）”，是“转位”，我说的是。我的音乐造诣还没达到普通人的水平。但肖恩很有品位。我的意思是，我热爱音乐。两秒钟你就能学会。
Inversions are the heart
of my music, I think.
I love that.
Not perversions, inversions, I said.
I'm not musically educated enough to normie.
But Shawnee is class.
I mean, I love music.
In two seconds you can learn.
C-E-G是一个C和弦。如果你把G拿下来放在最下面，突然之间，那就是一个164。如果你有一架钢琴，我可以在两秒钟内展示给你看。你们学得会非常快。这就是爵士乐发挥作用的地方，当你听你的钢琴时。我对爵士乐的看法是，这有点像，我随口说说的。这是一个惯用的玩笑，比如我不能，我的朋友马克·查普林（Mark Chaplin）我一直有，
C-E-G is a C-cord.
And if you take the G and you put it in the bottom,
all of a sudden, that's a 164.
If you're a piano, I could show you in two seconds.
You guys would learn so fast.
That's where jazz will come in when you listen to your piano.
I think my thing on jazz is, it's kind of, I said it's sort of offhand.
It's a running joke to, like, I can't, that my friend Mark Chaplin, I always have,
向查普（Chappie）致敬，不管是说喜欢它算酷还是说讨厌它算酷。这只是个玩笑，但实际上，他的儿子在伦敦的一所学校里学习爵士乐。但我确实觉得，我没有足够地欣赏它，我可能对它了解不够。我给你讲个故事。当我14岁的时候，我在一所……
which Chappie, shout out to Chappie, whether it's cool to say you like it or cool to say you don't.
It's just a joke, but it's actually, and his son is at a school taking jazz in London.
But I do, I think I don't appreciate it enough and I probably don't know enough about it.
I'll tell you a story.
When I was 14, I was at a.
It was called a grammar school.
I got a scholarship to study there.
It's like an elite school for poor kids.
它被称为文法学校（grammar school）。我得到了去那里学习的奖学金。就像是穷孩子的精英学校。我会带着我的吉他。一天下午，我在教室里弹琴，一个大一点的孩子走过来对我说：“你弹得很好。”他说：“你喜欢爵士乐吗？”我说：“我不知道。”他说：“我要给你个东西。”他给了我一张专辑，
And I would take my guitar.
And one afternoon I was playing in the classroom
and this older kid came up and said,
you're good.
He said, do you like jazz?
I said, I don't know.
He said, I'm going to give you something.
And he gave me an album.
说：“今晚听听看。你不会喜欢的，但明天晚上、后天晚上、大后天晚上还要听。”然后你就会学到一些东西。于是他给了我塞隆尼斯·孟克（Thelonious Monk）在巴黎奥林匹亚（Olympia）的现场独奏专辑。所以我放来听，他是对的，我不喜欢，听起来非常生硬、奇怪，全是古怪的和声狗屎。
He said, listen to it tonight.
You won't like it, but listen to it tomorrow night
and the next night and the next night.
and then you will learn something.
So he gave me Thelonius Monk playing live solo
at an Olympia in Paris, right?
So I put it on, he was right, I don't like it,
kind of really angular, weird, harmony shit.
我想我第二天晚上又放了一听，感觉稍微好了一点。到了第三天晚上，我大脑中一个一直关闭的区域被打开了。我想这就是接触高难度和声的过程。没有这种接触，你是听不懂的。你会说，哦，听起来真糟糕。但一旦你打开它，那是感觉最美妙的地方。哦，天哪，我要把它记下来。
I thought I put it on the next night, a little better.
By the third night, I'd opened up a part of my brain
that had been closed.
And I think it's about exposure to difficult harmony.
Without that exposure, you can't hear it.
You go, oh, it sounds terrible.
But once you open it, it's the sweetest place to be.
Oh, man, I'm going to write it.
太酷了。对，就是那个。我真的在把它记下来。什么是——我也是个音乐低能儿，但那些你可以轻松跟上、可以跟着踩拍子的东西是什么，4/4拍？对吗？我是说，普通拍子，对吧。
That's cool.
Yeah, it's that.
I'm literally reading this down.
What is the, I'm also a musical moron,
but the stuff that you can easily follow
that you can tap your toe to is what, 4-4 time?
Is that right?
I mean, common time, yeah.
大部分都是用4/4拍写的，是的。对。然后，那么，哪一种总是让你感到惊讶？是，那是像第三拍吗？好吧，可能是5/4拍，就像《Take Five》是用5/4拍写的。或者我喜欢7/8拍，一个小节里有7拍，或者像9/8拍。对于像我这样的笨蛋来说，听起来总像是个错误。就像他们怎么老是漏掉这一拍？
Most part of it's written in 4-4, yes.
Right.
And then so is it, what is the one that is always surprises you?
Is that, was that like third?
Well, it could be 5, 4, which is like take 5 is written in 5 4.
Or I like 7 8, 7 beats in a bar or like 9 8.
And to ding-dongs like me, it always sounds like it's a mistake.
Like how do they keep missing this?
对，对，但3/4拍是华尔兹。不过说到点子上去了，斯汀，它最终会让你成为一个更好的听众。它训练了你。你学会了如何去欣赏更具复杂性的东西，因此你不会像厌烦其他歌曲那样那么快就听腻这首歌。你说得对。正如你所知，大脑分为两部分。大脑的一部分负责分析或处理非常简单的音程，比如三度和五度。大脑的另一部分则负责分析更复杂的音程和更复杂的节奏。所以，除非你打开了大脑的一侧，
Yeah, yeah, but 3-4 is a wall.
But then to your point, Sting, it ends up,
making you a better listener. It trains you. You learn how to appreciate something that's a bit
more sophisticated and consequently you don't get sick of that song as quickly as you do the other ones.
You're right. I think the brain is split in two, as you know. One part of the brain
analyzes or processes very simple intervals like thirds and fifths. The other part of the brain
analyzes more complex intervals and more complex rhythms. So unless you've opened
one side of the brain
并且没有把它封闭起来，否则你将无法欣赏高难度的音乐。对，大多数人无法欣赏7/8拍、5/4拍、6/9拍或诸如此类拍子里的小众细微差别，就是这样。如果我和一把吉他即兴演奏，我总是用7拍在弹，我自己都不知道。
and not closed it off
you will not be able to appreciate difficult music
yeah and most people don't
appreciate those nuances in the 7-8 and the 5-4
and the 6-9 and whatever that's it
I do
if I'm jamming with a guitar I'm invariably playing in 7
I don't know it
我知道，你懂的——你要取笑我了——你对音乐剧《贝隆夫人》（Evita）的配乐了解多少？我了解。我敢打赌，如果你提醒我，我就会想起来。有一首歌我记不清了，那是，rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, three……
I am you know do you know this
you're going to make fun of me
do you know the score of Avita at all
I do
I'll bet I would if you told
it to me. There's one song that I can't remember
that was, rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling,
rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, three,
那是7/8拍，对吧？对，对，对，听起来有点像《西区故事》（West Side Story）里的歌。完全没错。对，有点像，采用了切分音。你知道的，斯汀，我第一次看到——当MTV刚开播时我还是个孩子，我看到的头几件事之一就是《Synchronicity 2》的音乐录影带，现在它仍然历历在目，我非常喜欢那首歌。我超喜欢那个MV。
that's seven, eight, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that sounds like a West Side Story one.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah, a little bit, like syncopated.
You know, Sting, the first time I ever saw,
I was a kid when MTV started, and one of the first things I ever saw was Synchronicity 2
video, which is still fresh in my mind, and I love that song.
I love that video.
你是一个拥抱视频时代与音频和歌曲相结合的人吗？还是你会想，天哪，我得拍这个MV。你讨厌它还是喜欢它？不，我认为英国乐队在MTV问世时具有明显的优势。因为英国当时只有一种流行音乐节目。它叫做《流行音乐排行榜》（Top of the Pops）。
Were you someone who embraced the advent of video
as it marries to audio and songs?
Or did you like, oh, God, I got to do this video.
Did you hate it or did you enjoy it?
No, I think British bands had distinct advantage
in the advent of MTV.
Because there was only one kind of pop show in England.
It was called Top of the Pops.
你是一个在视频与音频歌曲结合的时代到来时欣然接受的人吗？还是说，哦，天哪，我得拍这个视频了。你讨厌它还是喜欢它？不，我认为英国乐队在MTV时代到来时有着明显的优势。因为英格兰只有一种流行音乐节目。它叫做《Top of the Pops》。
It was a chart show.
and if you got into the top 20
you could perform on the show
and if your record went up
you'd perform the next week
but if you were on tour you had to make a video
and they'd show the video
so we had all of these
这是一个排行榜节目，如果你进入了前20名，你就能在节目中表演，如果你的唱片排名上升，你下周就能继续表演，但如果你在巡演，你就必须制作一个视频，他们会播放这个视频，所以我们有所有这些
examples of videos we'd made when we couldn't
turn up to actually do the show
that immediately went onto MTV
so we were well practiced
Oh wow
So that was
The second British invasion
was due to that fact
我们制作视频的例子，当我们无法到场亲自进行表演时，这些视频立刻就被放到了MTV上，所以我们经验丰富。哦，哇！所以那是……第二次英国入侵就是因为这个事实吗？
Was that the
Could that be
Was that the first time
You were in front of the camera
And started to
Maybe even have the spark of acting
No
那是……会不会是……那是你第一次站在镜头前并开始……甚至可能产生表演的火花吗？不，不。
I said I had a lot of jobs
I was trying to make a living in London
I modeled for a while
And I was
I went to an advertising agency
and I was modeling a, I think it was some kind of jewelry thing, and I was a punk, and it was shot by Ridley Scott.
Wow, wow, wow.
You had a company called RSA.
我说过我做过很多工作，我当时在伦敦努力谋生，我当过一段时间的模特，我去了一家广告公司，我当时在做……我想是某种珠宝类的模特，我当时是个朋克，那是雷德利·斯科特拍的。哇，哇，哇。你有一家叫RSA的公司。
Sure.
And I did a lot of work for them as a kind of model on film.
But, wait, so were these, was it print, were these, were stills, or was it moving?
No, this was for advertising in cinemas.
So in between movies.
So then the concept of striking a pose, making a face, conveying a mood, a tone through movement,
through expression, body language, etc.
That was interesting to you?
没错。我为他们做过很多工作，就像电影里的模特一样。但是，等等，所以这些是……是平面照，是静态照片，还是动态的？不，这是为电影院做的广告。也就是电影放映间隙的广告。那么，摆姿势、做鬼脸、通过动作、表情、肢体语言等传达一种情绪、一种格调的概念，你觉得这很有趣吗？
Did it have anything to do with performing on stage when you're doing music?
Like, I guess what I'm sort of prodig, I'm trying to do.
What is your attraction to acting and is it a cousin to what you like doing on stage?
I think I've been posing my entire life.
We all do it.
You know, I think I invented blue steel, frankly.
Yeah, you are the originator of many things.
Because I was in Zoolander too as well.
这和你做音乐时在舞台上的表演有什么关系吗？比如，我想我有点……我正在试着做。你对表演的吸引力是什么？它和你喜欢在舞台上做的事情有什么亲缘关系吗？我想我一辈子都在摆姿势。我们所有人都在这样做。你知道，坦白说，我觉得我发明了“电光蓝”。是啊，你是许多事物的鼻祖。因为我也参演了《名模大间谍2》。
Yeah, yeah.
With Mr. Justin Thoreau.
We had a lot to do with those.
Who actually proposed in my house.
Yeah.
And he said to me, do you think I should marry this girl?
I said, well, if you don't, I will.
I love it
对，对。和贾斯汀·塞洛克斯先生合作。我们和那些事很有渊源。他实际上是在我家求婚的。是啊。他对我说：“你觉得我应该娶这个女孩吗？”我说：“嗯，如果你不娶，我就娶。”我太喜欢了
Is that true?
Did he really propose in your house?
Would I lie to you?
No, it's true.
He comes to stay with us in Italy
in Tuscany.
That's amazing.
You know, it's funny, the police,
真的吗？他真的是在你家里求婚的吗？我会对你撒谎吗？不，这是真的。他来我们在意大利托斯卡纳的住所和我们一起住。太棒了。你知道，有趣的是，警察……
I mean, how many records did you guys release?
Five in five years, is that right?
Something like that?
I don't remember.
Something like that.
I mean, it's really,
I think your last, was your last record
synchronicity?
我是说，你们发行了多少张唱片？五年五张，对吗？差不多吧？我不记得了。差不多吧。我是说，真的，我觉得你们最后一张……你们最后一张唱片是《Synchronicity》吗？
Yes, it was.
And that was like 1983.
Wait, that was the last one?
Yeah, I know, isn't that amazing?
Yeah, but then going into, yeah, go.
And then you went into, right,
and then you went into everything else and all your...
A stratospheric solo career.
是的，是的。那是1983年左右。等等，那是最后一张吗？对，我知道，这不是很神奇吗？是啊，但随后进入……是的，继续。然后你进入了……没错，然后你进入了其他所有领域，还有你的……如日中天的个人音乐生涯。
Of course.
And do you, did it feel like you were going into a different phase?
like did it feel totally different coming out of being part of a band
and then going on in your own was it just like a...
What was that like?
Again, it was kind of strategic, you know,
and kind of counterintuitive.
You know, why would you leave the biggest band in the world at its peak?
当然。你觉得……你觉得自己当时是进入了一个不同的阶段吗？比如，从乐队中抽身出来，然后开始单飞，这种感觉完全不同吗？还是说这只是一种……那种感觉是什么样的？同样，这有点像是一种策略，你知道的，也有点反直觉。你知道，你为什么要在一个乐队的巅峰时期离开世界上最伟大的乐队呢？
Yeah.
I said, well, after this, everything's going to be diminishing returns.
I want to start the adventure again and take that risk.
and also if I don't leave now
I'll never be able to leave
yeah
you know I mean
I love the stones
是的。我说，好吧，在这之后，一切都会盛极而衰。我想重新开始冒险，去承担那个风险。而且如果我现在不离开，我将永远无法离开。是啊，你知道我的意思，我很喜欢滚石乐队
the stones are fantastic
but they are welded together
yeah
they are
I wanted to leave the band before
that weld was entirely
I just wanted some freedom
right right yeah
滚石乐队棒极了，但他们被焊在了一起，是的，确实如此。我想在那种焊接完全形成之前离开乐队。我只是想要点自由，对吧，对吧，是的。
and the music
while it was
different
it's still there was there was always a complexity to what you guys were doing just as a three-man band and when you went off and created another band yes it was it was titled just your name but the musicians you put together were just incredible and that band as a unit made some incredibly complicated music i was so glad to see the what was the name of the documentary of the recording of dream of the blue turtles
Bring on the night.
Oh, fuck, I love that movie.
And watching you guys,
而且音乐虽然不同，但它依然存在……你们所做的事情一直有一种复杂性，仅仅作为一个三人乐队，当你离开并创建了另一个乐队时，是的，它的名字只是你的名字，但你召集的音乐家简直不可思议，作为整体，那个乐队创作了一些极其复杂的音乐。我很高兴看到……录制《蓝海龟之梦》的那部纪录片叫什么名字？《迎向黑夜》。《迎向黑夜》。哦，操，我太喜欢那部电影了。看着你们，
it was in some gorgeous chateau
or a manor or something,
was just watching you guys do what you did.
There was such a, yes, you were the leader,
but the sharing, the camaraderie that you created with them,
it was so nice to see you guys all working together
as co-equals to create what you guys did.
You know, one of my strategies has always been to,
那是在某个华丽的城堡或庄园里，看着你们做着你们所做的事。有一种……是的，你是队长，但你与他们建立的分享、那种情谊，看到你们所有人作为平等合作者一起工作来创造你们所做的事情，感觉真是太棒了。你知道，我的策略之一一直是……
to play with musicians who were better than me
so that I would have to raise my game.
That was true with the police.
That was true with the Blue Turtles,
and it's true now.
I'm still struggling to maintain my position
because I hire people, though, way better than me.
Yeah.
与比我更好的音乐人合作，这样我就必须提高我的水平。在警察乐队时是这样，在蓝海龟乐队时是这样，现在也是这样。我仍然在努力保持我的地位，因为我雇佣的人，依然比我优秀得多。是的。
Yeah, so talk to us about that, about 3.0
and about what excited you about creating that,
and what's the goal there?
The goal was really to strip the songs down
to their bare skeletal form
and see if there was still sturdy enough
to stand without all that flesh on it.
And lo and behold,
是的，所以跟我们聊聊这个，关于3.0乐队，以及是什么让你对创作这个感到兴奋，那里的目标是什么？目标其实是将歌曲剥离到它们精简的骨架形式，看看它们在没有所有那些血肉的情况下是否仍然足够坚挺，能够立足。结果呢，
there's so much air around the instruments and clarity
that it is both louder and quieter at the same time.
The dynamics are much more extreme.
Meaning that you've taken just the three,
three fellas and you've stripped away a bunch of other things.
And when you say the songs, you're talking about songs that include the entirety of your career
or just recently or what?
Just take away the keyboard parts, all the layered synthesizer parts, the strings.
乐器周围有如此多的空间和清晰度，以至于它同时既更响亮又更安静。动态范围要极端得多。这意味着你只带了那三个人，三位老兄，然后剥离了其他很多东西。当你说“歌曲”时，你指的是涵盖你整个职业生涯的歌曲，还是仅仅是最近的，或者是什么？仅仅去掉键盘部分，所有分层的合成器部分，弦乐。
And you're just left with guitar, bass, drums, and a voice.
It's amazing how sturdy those songs are.
I bet.
I mean, it's such a testament to them themselves, you know, the songs themselves.
Are you still on tour with that?
Yeah, in between shows with the last ship, I'm touring with a band.
I'm trying to keep both things in there because I love them both.
You just announced new dates, right?
你剩下的只有吉他、贝斯、鼓和人声。这些歌竟然如此经久不衰，真是太神奇了。我敢说。我是说，这本身就是对它们的一种证明，你知道，歌曲本身。你还在带着那个巡演吗？是的，在与《最后之船》的演出间隙，我和一支乐队在巡演。我试图把这两件事都兼顾起来，因为我都爱。你刚刚宣布了新的演出日期，对吧？
I think there's going to be a domestic or U.S. tour in May, I want to say?
Yeah, May.
In May and then November.
Wow.
I'm coming back for the midterms.
We need you.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
我想今年五月会有一场国内或美国的巡演，我想是吧？对，五月。在五月，然后是十一月。哇。我为中期选举回来。我们需要你。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。
Mixed in all of this, it should be noted,
you've spent a lot of your time throughout your life
devoted to activism for a lot of different causes.
Yeah, like serious.
Well, yeah, I remember the, what was it,
the secret policeman's other ball.
You're part of that.
I was the first time you performed solo, is that correct?
应该指出的是，夹杂在这一切之中的是，你一生中把很多时间都奉献给了各种不同事业的激进主义。是的，就像认真的那种。好吧，是的，我记得那个……叫什么来着，“秘密警察的另一个舞会”。你是其中的一部分。那是我第一次进行个人表演，对吗？
Well, first time since I became famous, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you did that and Band-Aid and all these things.
And then you've continued amnesty and stuff over the years.
Where does that sort of fit in your life?
Well, I've always had a social conscience.
I think as a member of society, you have a debt to society.
Noblesse oblige.
嗯，自从我出名以来的第一次，是的。对，对，对。但你做了那个、Band-Aid以及所有这些事情。然后多年来你一直继续参与大赦国际等活动。这在你生活中扮演什么角色？嗯，我一直有社会良知。我认为作为社会的一员，你对社会负有债务。贵族义务。
Noblese oblige.
Very good, French.
It's never been a question for me that I wouldn't be involved in issues like that.
I still am.
I mean, I don't write songs that are propaganda.
You know, I am always looking for a metaphor that I can express an idea in
without just saying, you're good and you're bad.
I have to have a metaphor.
贵族义务。非常好，法语。对我来说，不参与这种问题从来都不是一个问题。我到现在还在参与。我是说，我不写带有宣传性质的歌曲。你知道，我一直在寻找一个隐喻，我可以用它来表达一个想法，而不是仅仅说“你是好人，你是坏人”。我必须有一个隐喻。
How are we doing in some of those areas that you're passionate about,
the rainforests and others?
Well, it's pretty bleak, to be honest with you.
You know, we protected an area of the rainforest.
My wife and I, the size of Belgium and the Netherlands.
And then with the Bolsonaro government,
they just made incursions into that protectorate.
So it's bleak.
在我们热衷的某些领域，比如热带雨林和其他领域，我们现在做得怎么样？嗯，说实话，前景相当黯淡。你知道的，我们保护了一片热带雨林。我和我妻子，面积相当于比利时和荷兰的总和。然后随着博索纳罗政府上台，他们直接侵入了那个保护区。所以前景黯淡。
It's not a good picture at the moment.
Do you think that, speaking of AI,
do you see AI as something that could be helpful
in something like that?
Well, I mean, if it's truly intelligent,
it will tell us to stop burning the rainforest
and stop polluting our rivers.
And it may come up with some sort of an alternative.
目前情况不太妙。你觉得，说到人工智能，你认为人工智能有可能在类似的事情上提供帮助吗？嗯，我是说，如果它真的有智能，它会告诉我们停止砍伐雨林，停止污染我们的河流。而且它可能会想出某种替代方案。
I get why you're burning it because you need X,
but here's another way you could get X.
Yeah.
Maybe that would be a useful,
or medical research, I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Jason, I'm applauding your optimism right now.
Yeah, I really...
我理解你为什么要砍伐它，因为你需要X，但这是你可以获得X的另一种方式。是的。也许那会很有用，或者医学研究，我确定。是的，是的。杰森，我正在为你的乐观主义鼓掌。是的，我真的……
This is a new...
I did see, I think I was telling you guys
about the documentary I saw the other day.
I want to give a little plug to it.
It was so fantastic.
It was called the AI document,
the AI doc,
can't wait.
这是一个新的……我确实看到，我想我之前在跟你们讲我前几天看的那部纪录片。我想为它打个小广告。太棒了。它叫人工智能纪实，AI doc，迫不及待。
With the subtitle of how I became an apocalyptic.
And it's,
it's about,
it's about a guy who's about to have a child.
And he is simply taking the position of the layman
and saying to all of these experts,
should I be worried about having a kid coming into this world,
given what we're hearing?
副标题是“我是如何成为一个末日论者的”。它讲的是一个即将迎来孩子的父亲。他只是站在门外汉的立场上，对所有这些专家说：鉴于我们所听到的，我应该为把孩子带到这个世界上感到担心吗？
Should I be bullish or pessimistic about,
about AI's contribution of society?
and mankind. And it was not only a really entertaining documentary, but super educational,
and I did come out the other side optimistic. And so I would ask our guest here, you know,
maybe specifically to music, but also just in general, if you're willing to give us your hot take
on what you think AI is going to do for us. Well, I'll speak about my field,
talk about music. You know, AI can create perfectly serviceable
pop music that you would hear in a hotel lobby or an airport.
我对人工智能对社会和人类的贡献到底是该感到乐观还是悲观？这不仅是一部非常具有娱乐性的纪录片，而且超级有教育意义，我最终还是带着乐观的心态走出来了。所以我想问这里的嘉宾，你知道的，也许具体到音乐，但也泛指一般情况，如果你愿意的话，跟我们分享一下你对人工智能将为我们做些什么的犀利见解。好吧，我只谈我的领域，聊聊音乐。你知道，人工智能可以创作出完美的、中规中矩的流行音乐，你会在酒店大堂或机场听到。
But there's a difference between listening to something and hearing something.
So I'm saying you'll hear that in an airport.
I will know it's AI almost immediately.
But will I listen to it?
No.
What I'm listening for in a piece of music created by a human being is that that human being has
lived a life.
That human being has had its heartbroken, has been in love.
但听音乐和听到声音是有区别的。所以我说你会在机场听到那种音乐。我几乎立刻就能听出那是人工智能。但我会去听它吗？不会。我在人类创作的一段音乐中所寻找的是，那个度过了一生的人类。那个经历过心碎、体验过爱的人类。
A machine can't do that.
Machine doesn't have a family history, good or bad.
It's just a set of other people's memories.
So I don't think we are in danger of losing that.
I think people will know that this is a machine that's singing to them,
and it's not real.
I hope so anyway.
And do you think that maybe, hopefully, one of the byproducts will be
机器做不到这一点。机器没有家族史，无论好坏。它只是一组别人的记忆。所以我认为我们没有失去这一点的危险。人们会知道这是一个机器在对他们唱歌，这不是真实的。无论如何我希望如此。你觉得也许，希望如此，其中一个副产品会是
that people will really celebrate and really there will be a premium,
for live experiences with other human beings.
Like, that will be hopefully one of the byproduct.
I agree.
Also, you know, you're competing with a kind of perfectionism
that machines can give you.
Now, I think artists in the 19th century, visual artists,
were challenged by the invention of photography.
人们会真正地赞美，并且真正地会出现一种溢价，为了与其他人类的现场体验。这希望会成为副产品之一。我同意。另外，你知道，你在与机器能带给你的那种完美主义竞争。现在，我认为19世纪的艺术家、视觉艺术家，曾受到摄影发明的挑战。
That could create reality in such a detailed way.
So instead of trying to compete,
they created the Impressionist movement,
where they weren't painting objects anymore,
they were painting the light around objects.
And that, I think human beings will sidestep that perfection
to create something better.
Yeah, it's almost going back to what we're talking about with jazz.
摄影能以如此详细的方式创造现实。所以他们没有选择去竞争，而是创造了印象派运动，他们不再画物体，而是画物体周围的光。我认为人类会绕过这种完美去创造更好的东西。是的，这几乎回到了我们刚才谈论的爵士乐。
It's jazz by intention and by definition is improvisational
and is meant to sort of mess it up a little bit.
Like, you know, you can play the four-four time and make it all work,
but it takes a real master to kind of identify the gray areas around that
and kind of bend it and tweak it a little bit
and then re-arrive at something
that's perhaps a little bit more predictable
and then break it again.
爵士乐凭其意图和定义就是即兴的，注定要稍微把事情弄得有点凌乱。就像，你知道，你可以演奏四四拍然后让它一切运转，但要真正找出周围的灰色地带并将其扭曲、微调一点，然后再次回归到一个或许稍微更可预测的东西，然后再将其打破，这需要真正的大师。
I doubt a computer would be able to be that sophisticated.
We have to go through whatever phase this is
and humanity of this AI to come back.
Look, vinyl's back.
Like, everything comes back, you know?
Well, yeah, think about vinyl.
I mean, when we went to,
what was your feeling when they started going digital
我怀疑计算机是否能有那么高的复杂性。我们必须经历人工智能的这个阶段以及人性的这个阶段，才能回归。看，黑胶唱片回归了！就像，一切都会回归，你知道的？嗯，是的，想想黑胶唱片。我是说，当我们转向……当他们开始转向数字化时，你的感受是什么？
to sort of CDs and stuff
and that kind of compressed sound and all that added that effect.
I mean, we kind of enjoyed it.
I liked CDs, but there's something uncanny about digital silence
instead of that white hissy noise you get on and put a record on,
which is kind of comforting.
Yeah, sure.
Digital silence is very spooky.
转向CD之类的东西，那种压缩的声音以及所有增加的效果。我是说，我们其实挺喜欢的。我喜欢CD，但数字寂静有一种诡异的感觉，而放上一张唱片时听到的那种嘶嘶的白噪音，感觉有点安慰。是的，当然。数字寂静非常诡异。
It is.
It's kind of like film, too, right?
You actually see film, you see some of the hair
and some of the noise on the image, whereas the digital stuff is so cool.
And also the experience of like going out when I was a kid and forgive me again for like going out and buying one of your records.
And the day it came out and cutting the plastic on it.
Yeah, the cellophane.
And then taking it out and putting it on the record player and looking at the lyrics and singing that was the only connection that you had.
确实如此。这有点像胶片，对吧？你实际上能看到胶片，能在画面上看到一些发丝和一些噪点，而数字的东西太冷了。还有那种经历，就像我小时候出去——请再次原谅我——出去买你的其中一张唱片。唱片发行的那一天，划开上面的塑料膜。是的，玻璃纸。然后把它拿出来，放到唱片机上，看着歌词唱歌，那是你唯一的连接。
And it was so exciting.
You know, like I just went out and I got the new Sting record.
I got the new police record.
Like, you know, that experience
where we're robbing ourselves
of these experiences.
It was an entire world, you know.
I mean, you can stream songs now,
那太令人兴奋了。你知道，就像我刚刚出去买了一张新的斯汀唱片。我买了张新的警察乐队唱片。就像，你知道，那种我们在剥夺自己这些体验的经历。那是一个完整的世界，你知道的。我是说，你现在可以串流播放歌曲，
but they don't tell you who played bass on them.
They don't tell you who was the engineer,
you know, where it was made.
It's just a product like coffee.
It's a commodity.
So you need that information.
An album covers satisfied an entire generation,
which I'm part of.
但它们不会告诉你谁在里面弹了贝斯。它们不会告诉你谁是录音师，是在哪里制作的。它只是像咖啡一样的一个产品。它是一种商品。所以你需要这些信息。一张专辑封面满足了一整代人，我也是其中之一。
I remember that.
That was our world.
Yeah.
You'd listen and stare at this,
stare at the album cover for hours as you were listening to every detail of it.
I did that with The Carpenter's. I used to listen to The Carpenter's so much.
Let's move on.
Hey, Sting, are we ever going to see you do some acting again?
我记得那点。那是我们的世界。是的。你会一边听一边盯着这个，盯着专辑封面数小时，聆听它的每一个细节。我听《木匠乐队》时就是这样。我以前经常听《木匠乐队》。我们继续吧。嘿，斯汀，我们还能看到你再次进行表演吗？
Because you're a great actor.
I'm acting in my play.
I'm in my play, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, and I'm going to come see that.
I'll be the guy.
in front heckling and judging.
Will you go see him backstage, Jason?
I'm going to come see him backstage,
因为你是个优秀的演员。我在我的戏剧里演戏。我在我的戏剧里，对，对，对。是的，我要去看那场演出。我会成为那个站在前面起哄和评判的人。你会去后台看他吗，杰森？我要去后台看他，
which I always find is a little sweaty,
but I'm told that's what the polite thing is to do.
Do you like that?
Do you like people coming backstage?
Yeah, I do.
You're not exhausted and you just want to go home or you want...
No, I want adulation.
All right, I'm going to come back.
我总是觉得这有点让人出汗，但别人告诉我这才是礼貌的做法。你喜欢那样吗？你喜欢人们去后台吗？是的，我喜欢。你不是筋疲力尽只想回家或者想……不，我想要阿谀奉承。好吧，我要回来。
I'm just going to just fawn all over here.
You need to know that this is a thing for Jason
that we've been due for years
about the question as to whether or not to go backstage.
What about after a concert?
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, actually, I usually leave the building immediately
我打算对你大加吹捧。你需要知道，杰森一直在纠结是否要去后台这个问题，我们已经讨论好几年了。音乐会结束后呢？哦。好吧，通常我会在演出结束后立即离开大楼，以防他们要求退款。但《最后之船》，他们不要求。他们可以过来直接说太棒了。所以斯汀，你知道的，我们刚刚列举了你做过的和没做过的一切。你简直就像是世界上最努力工作的人。我是说，你……你刚刚说“看起来最难看”？
in case they want their money back.
But the last shit, they don't.
They can just come and say great.
So Sting, you know, we just listed all of the things that you do
and that you don't.
It just seems like you're the hardest working person in the world.
I mean, what do you...
Did you say hardest-looking?
工作最努力。好吧。两者我都接受。两者我都接受。看起来最难看。就凭你做过的所有慈善工作，所有的音乐会，所有的，你在做现场演出，你在巡演，你在写更多的专辑。
Hardest working.
Okay.
I'll take both.
Hardest-looking.
Just with all the charity work you do, all the concerts you do,
all the, you're doing a live show, you're doing a tour,
you're writing more albums.
简直没完没了。太不可思议了。就像你说的，你的职业道德简直不可思议。问题是，什么时候你觉得自己像个傻子？对吧？是的。你做过什么蠢得像狗屎一样的事？你知道，同意上这个节目，也许吧？
It's just endless.
It's incredible.
Like you said, your work ethic is just incredible.
The question is, yeah, when are you an idiot?
Right?
Yeah.
What do you do that's just dumb as shit?
You know, agreeing to do this show, maybe?
是的，当然，你请便。懊悔一定巨大。你看到了节目的名字。你说，完美。那就是我。Smartless。好吧。你有任何内疚感，觉得我的大脑需要休息一下？
Yeah, sure you go.
The regret must be immense.
You saw the title of it.
You said, perfect.
That's me.
Smart less.
Okay.
Like, do you have any guilty sort of that my brain needs to rest and do?
我当然有，但我不会告诉你。少来。哦，不，你得告诉我们。肖恩喜欢手机上的“糖果粉碎传奇”。是的。我不知道那是什么。是的，那是个愚蠢的小游戏。不过我想象，或者只是和伟大的特鲁迪·斯泰勒一起进行美好的长途散步？
Of course I do, but I'm not going to tell you.
Come on.
Oh, no, you got to tell us.
Sean likes Candy Crush on his phone.
Yeah.
I've no idea what that is.
Yeah, it's some dumb little game.
But I would imagine, or is it just nice long walks with the great Trudy Stiler?
你知道，我在爱情方面非常有天赋。我有一个漂亮的女人，她做了我45年的伴侣。这就好像是，你知道的，从第二次世界大战开始。我们在一起度过了美好的时光。我们相爱。我是说，老实说，我其实有六周时间，因为我明天要去澳大利亚演《最后之船》。这太久了，对吧？
You know, I'm very gifted in love.
I have this beautiful woman who's been my partner for 45 years.
That's like, you know, since the Second World War.
And we just have a great time.
We love each other.
I mean, I honestly have for six weeks, actually,
because I'm going to Australia tomorrow to do the last ship.
That's too long, right?
我敢打赌你们像我们其他人一样有个“两周规则”？你们能很好地遵守吗？通常可以，但这是一个很长的时间段。是的。是的，这是一个很长的时间。你觉得日复一日地做这场演出感觉如何？就像我总是说的，最难的部分是如果你感觉糟透了，或者胃痛，或者头痛，或者无论什么情况，你都必须坚持，你必须上台。你知道，《最后之船》有两出戏在上演。一出是在舞台上，观众能看到的。
I bet you guys have a two-week rule like the rest of us?
Are you good about keeping that?
Normally, but this is a long period.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a long.
time. What do you think about doing the show night after night? Like I always said the hardest part is
if you're feeling like shit or you got a stomachache or your headache or whatever, you have to
keep, you have to go on. You know, there are two plays going on with the last ship. There's one that's
后台还有另一出。在戏剧的某个时刻，你会在后台遇到一些小家伙，那是你和舞台前的人一起歌唱的时候，或者你们在那里进行拍手比赛，有一些你永远不会停下来的小仪式，你同时在演两出戏，我知道我必须在什么位置
on stage at the audience sees. There's another one behind the stage. You meet little pleaks
behind stage at a certain point in the play and that's when you sing along with the person
in front of the stage
or you have a hand-clapping competition
there are little rituals that
you never stop
you're doing both plays
and I know where I have to be
我们都是这样。你对……你以前用什么在大都会歌剧院演出过吗？我曾和我的乐队在大都会歌剧院演出过几次，但这实际上是我第一次参演
and we all do that
are you excited about
have you played the Met before
with anything?
I've performed at the Met
with my band a couple of times
but this is the first time
I've actually been in
在大都会歌剧院上演的戏剧，这是一个巨大的剧院，但戏剧的布景非常巨大。我们在重现一个造船厂，它具有歌剧的规模。它不是歌剧，但它有
a play
in the Met and it's a massive
theater but the set
of the play is so huge.
We are recreating a shipyard
and it has an
operatic scale.
It's not an opera, but it has
歌剧的规模。另外，我认为它具有歌剧的情感野心。这是一部非常感人的戏剧。我迫不及待地想看这个。是的。那么大都会歌剧院的布景改变了吗？它们造得更大了吗？它们更戏剧化了吗？
an operatic scale.
Also, I think it has the emotional
ambition of an opera. It's a very
emotional play. I can't wait to
see this. Yeah. And so
did the sets
change for the Met?
Are they built bigger? Are they more dramatic?
因为那个场馆，它们更具歌剧感了吗？因为场馆的缘故，它们变得更大了。我们最初在阿姆斯特丹，然后我们在巴黎的巨大音乐厅里，效果确实很好。写一部歌剧或写一部交响乐怎么样？这些对你有吸引力吗？我是一个词曲作家，《最后之船》是一个歌曲套曲，你知道的，带有戏剧成分。但要写一部歌剧，我不知道。我没有资格做那种事。
Are they more operatic because of that venue?
They're bigger because of the venue.
We started out in Amsterdam, and then we were in Paris in massive halls, and it really works.
What about writing an opera or writing a symphony?
Is any of that interesting to you?
I'm a songwriter, and the last ship was a song cycle, you know, with a theatrical component to it.
But to write an opera, I don't know.
I'm not qualified to do that.
这听起来像是一个非常坚决的拒绝。我正想着，斯汀，你在我最喜欢的电影之一《四重人格》中的表演。嗯，我在那部电影里待的时间足够留下深刻印象，但又不足以搞砸它。不，但这是一部非常棒的电影。你们看过那部电影吗，《四重人格》？没有，我只看过片段。
That feels like a pretty hard, no.
I'm just remembering Sting, your performance in one of my favorite films,
Valtite, which is Quadrophenia.
Well, I was in that film long enough to make an impression,
but not long enough to blow it.
No, but it's such a great film.
Have you guys ever seen that, Quadrophenia?
No, I have little pieces.
是的。我很想看到你更多的表演。嗯，那是在我做模特和什么都干的那段时期，你知道的，为了在鸡尾酒吧找份差事，
Yeah.
I would love to see more.
acting out of you.
Well, that was during the period
when I was modeling
and just doing anything,
you know, trying to get a gig
in the cocktail bar,
所以我什么都愿意做。有个经纪人打电话给我，说你想不想去试镜《四重人格》？我说，不，我在洗头，但她说，不，去吧。我很喜欢原版的《沙丘》。我非常喜欢你在原版《沙丘》中的表现。你看过新版的吗？
so I would do anything.
This agent called me up,
said, do you want to go for quadrufini?
I said, nah, I'm washing my hair,
but she's, no, go.
I loved the original Dune.
I loved you in the original Dune.
Have you seen the new ones?
看过。是的，挺酷的。是的，它们挺酷的。我觉得奥斯汀·巴特勒在新版里演的是我。是的，绝对的。太棒了。两个帅哥。两个帅哥的事情。
Yeah.
Yeah, pretty cool.
Yeah, they're pretty cool.
I think Austin Butler was playing me
in the new one.
Yeah, for sure.
It's great.
Two handsome guys. Two handsome guys things.
对，没错。我是说，他们的版本没有我的那么夸张。我必须这么说。是的，那是大卫·林奇导演的，对吧？是的。好吧，我非常感谢你花时间陪我们。哦，天哪，太激动人心了。让我们得以通过你的才华、你的成就，稍微窥探一下幕后。
Yeah, that's right.
I mean, their version wasn't as a camp as I was.
I have to tell you.
Yeah, it was David Lynch, wasn't it?
Yeah.
Well, I can't thank you enough for spending time with us.
Oh, my gosh, what a thrill.
And letting us peek behind the curtain a bit with your brilliance, your accomplishments.
我是说，有没有什么东西值得我们拭目以待，也就是你接下来也要去尝试完善的？我是说，你做过的一切，都那么不同，那么不可思议。外面还有什么挑战在等着你吗？我认为所有艺术的基础——并非装腔作势——就是惊喜。在一首作品中，你希望在四个小节内给人们带来惊喜
I mean, is there anything we should keep our knees bent for
that you're going to try to also perfect.
I mean, everything you've done,
it's all been so different and so incredible.
Is there a challenge for you out there left?
I think the basis of all art,
not to be pretentious, but it is surprise.
In a composition, you want to surprise people within four bars
或是一段文字。你希望在前几句话内给人们带来惊喜。所以我希望关于接下来会发生什么，能给自己一个惊喜。我不知道接下来是什么。但我必须有惊喜。我必须有新鲜感。我对无聊的忍耐度很低。所以我需要感到惊喜。
or a piece of writing.
You want to surprise people within the first few sentences.
So I'm hoping to surprise myself about what is next.
I don't know what is next.
But I have to have surprise.
I have to have novelty.
I have a very low threshold for boredom.
So I need to be surprised.
是的。我想象——我希望这个问题的答案是“是”——你已经让自己感到满足，同时又为你所做的一切感到自豪，并且你不需要向自己或我们证明任何什么，接下来的一切纯粹只是为了好玩。你允许自己去审视已取得的成就吗？我是说，那简直太不可思议了。
Yeah.
And I would imagine, I hope the answer to this is yes,
that you have allowed yourself to be satisfied
and yet even proud of what you've done
and that you need not prove anything to yourself or to us
and that it's just all just sort of for fun going forward.
Do you allow yourself the observation of accomplishment?
I mean, it's just been incredible.
我是说，在每一个重要领域，我都算是一个非常幸运的人。是的。我有一个家庭，一个妻子，还有一份事业。是的，而且，是的，我一直很幸运。好吧，我们非常幸运能接收到这一切。所以谢谢你，请继续保持。我可以问你关于，比如，你的……我是说，当我遇到像你这样的人时，它是如此具有标志性，我只想跟你聊聊每个人，你所有歌曲背后的故事是什么？我知道，我知道。
I mean, I'm a very fortunate man in every, you know, important field.
Yeah.
I have a family, I have a wife, and a career.
And, yeah, I've been very fortunate.
Well, we're very fortunate to have received it all.
So thank you and please keep it going.
I could ask you about, like, you're, I mean, it's, when I meet somebody like you, it's so massively iconic, I just want to talk you about how every, what's the story behind every song that you could ever, I know, I know.
你会花上几个小时又几个小时吗？你知道吗，我自己会在较小的场馆办一场演出，那里有提供为歌曲提供背景的机会。哇。我说，好吧，我是在贝斯沃特的公寓里写的，或者是什么启发了我，或者它是如何被创作出来的。我认为这些背景会让歌曲更丰富。是的。但你在竞技场或体育场里显然做不到这一点。
Would you take hours and hours?
You know what, I do a show on my own in a smaller venues where it affords the opportunity to give context to the songs.
Wow.
I said, okay, I wrote it in the flat in Bayswater,
or this was what inspired me, or how it was written.
And I think that context makes the songs richer.
Yeah.
But you can't do that in an arena or a stadium, obviously.
但在一个可能只有100人的小地方，你真的可以创造出歌曲诞生的那个世界。你还会这样做吗，你还会不时地这样做吗？是的，我两周前刚做过一场。哦，天哪，我想去看那个。是的，是吗？那不是斯汀3.0，对吧？其中会包含一些那样的内容吗？
But in a small place with maybe 100 people,
you can really create the world that the songs came from.
And you will still do that, you'll still do that from time to time?
Yeah, I did one two weeks ago.
Oh, man, I want to come and see that.
Yeah, is that?
That's not Sting 3.0, is it?
Do there some of that in that?
只是有时我会搞一场单场演出，仅仅是为了表演一小时我的歌曲和故事。我很想看那个。哦，那会很棒。我很想看那个。非常感谢，老兄。非常感谢你抽出时间。谢谢。几个月后我会去敲你的化妆室门的。
It's just sometimes I'll do one-off just to do an hour of my songs and stories.
I love to see that.
Ooh, that would be good.
I'd love to see that.
Thank you so much, man.
I really appreciate the time.
Thank you.
I'll be banging on your dressing room door in a couple of months.
假装你还记得我。请务必记得。我可能会和他们在一起。请务必记得。好吧，祝你接下来的时间过得愉快！再次感谢你加入我们。我有封面。你直接“啪”地合上就行。
Pretend you remember me.
Please do.
I might be with them.
All right, will you enjoy the rest of your day?
Thank you again for joining us.
I have my cover.
You can just slam it shut.
非常感谢你抽出时间，斯汀。祝斯汀3.0和《最后之船》一切顺利。太有趣了。非常感谢。好啦，再见。拜拜。拜拜，谢谢。
Really appreciate the time, Sting.
Good luck with Sting 3.0 and the last ship.
That was fun.
Thank you so much.
All right, cheers me.
Bye.
Bye, thank you.
哇，杰森。是啊，觉得怎么样？哇。当他冒出来的时候……当你问他得了多少格莱美奖时，他当时的反应就像，这是谁？17座格莱美奖。1亿张唱片。这太不可思议了。
Wow, Jason.
Yeah, how about that?
Wow.
When he popped out, well, when you said how many grant,
Grammys he went like, who is this?
17 Grammys.
100 million records.
That's unbelievable.
我觉得他快接近EGOT（艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖、托尼奖大满贯）水平了，而且正如我所说，他真的是从1969年开始的，那正是我出生的那一年，而且在我记忆所及的年少时期里，他一直都是那个人，并贯穿了我所有欣赏音乐的岁月。
I think he's like close to Egot
level and just he's across
as I said he literally started in 1969
so that was a year I was born
and as young as I can remember
he has been
the guy and is across
all of my years of music appreciation
在我喜欢听音乐的每一年里，他都有我喜欢听的音乐。我喜欢这样，是的，这太棒了。等等，69年是他开始演出的年份。和警察乐队一起，还是？不，开始表演音乐，我猜，作为一个孩子或在学习音乐的时候。警察乐队大概是1978年吧，我想。哦，好吧，好吧。
every single year I've liked listening to music,
he's had music that I loved listening to.
I love that, yeah, that's great.
Wait 69 was the year he started performing.
With the police or?
No, started performing music, I guess, as a kid or learning the music.
The police was like 1978, I think.
Oh, okay, okay.
我觉得，是的，听起来差不多。差不多吧。你怎么对这个这么了解？因为我是……你知道动物有多疯狂。所有那些唱片对我来说都太重要了。就像其他人一样。我在这方面并不独特。即使你不是粉丝——虽然我无法相信有人不是——
I think that, yeah, that sounds about right.
Something like that.
How do you know that well?
Because I'm, you know how crazy animals.
All those records were just so important to me.
Like everybody else.
I'm not unique in that way.
And even if you're not a fan, which I can't believe anybody isn't,
你也知道他所有的歌。对。当然。你知道我的意思吗？它们全都不一样。他的每一首歌听起来都不像上一首。我知道。太疯狂了。
you know all his songs.
Right.
Of course.
You know what I mean?
They're all different.
Not one of his songs sounds like the last.
I know.
Pretty crazy.
是的。仅凭警察乐队，他们只有三个人，却能做出所有那些不同的声音。哦，天哪。他真的，真的很让人印象深刻。我是说真的，我很想看他更多的表演。他说他的表演风格有一种极佳的庄重感
Yeah.
And just the police alone, the fact that it was just three of them too,
making all those different sounds.
Oh, my God.
He's really, really impressive.
And I'm serious, I would love to see more acting out of him.
He says it's such a great president.
and stillness to his acting style, which I'm a big, big fan of.
和宁静感，我是他的超级超级粉丝。但，是的，当……你知道，我在想当我……在这次采访前做简短的粗略研究时，这完美地体现了我们三个人到底有多他妈的幸运。我知道。当他弹出来的那一刻我就这么想了。就像，你知道的，他一直是一个同一个人，对吧？我是说，这家伙一直……当他对我来说就像一个神时我还小，他现在依然是。就像，现在我们能把他请到我们的节目上。
But yeah, what it, you know, I was thinking about when I was, you know,
doing, you know, my brief research before this interview,
this is a perfect example of how freaking lucky the three of us are.
I know.
I thought that right when he popped on.
Like, you know, he's been a same, right?
I mean, this guy's been like, I was a little guy when he was like a god to me and he still is.
And like, now we get to have him on our show.
就像，我记得在好莱坞公园，在这里的赛马场看警察乐队的演出。而且，你知道的，离舞台有一英里远，因为那是能买到的最近的票。世界上最大牌的摇滚巨星就在那么远的地方。我永远也无法接近像现在这样的人。所以我们能和这些人对话并向他们提问。就像我和我姐姐坐在起居室里用唱片机听唱片一样。是的。
Like, I remember seeing the police at the Hollywood Park, at the racetrack here.
And, you know, being a mile from the stage, because that's the closest tickets I could get.
And there's like the biggest rock star in the world that far away.
I'll never get anywhere near somebody like now.
So we get to talk to these folks and ask them questions.
I have like sitting in the living room with my sisters
like listening to the records on the record player.
Yeah.
听着唱片的噼啪声。完全是这样。想象一下如果卡伦·卡彭特还活着。哦，肖恩。不管怎样，继续。是的，从没提过这事。真的，真的太幸运了。我知道。我知道。他一上场我就有这种感觉，
And listen like the snap crackle pop of the record.
Totally. Imagine if Karen Carpenter was still alive.
Oh, Sean.
Anyway, moving on.
Yeah, it's never addressed it.
Truly, truly so lucky.
I know.
I know. I felt that right when he came on,
我就想，哇，这简直太不可思议了。非常感谢所有正在收听的听众，是你们让这一切成为可能。让我们这些斯汀迷的童年梦想成真，呃，谢谢你们，我们……我们非常……我们……他说他非常幸运，我们……我们非常幸运能和这些不可思议的人共度时光。是的，我们在很多方面都非常幸运，而这绝对是极其重要的一件，呃，换句话说，我们并没有受到太大的虐待……哦，备受折磨。
I was like, wow, this is just incredible.
A big thank you to those of you who are listening
that make it possible.
for us sting don'ts to have these childhood dreams come true uh thank you we we are very we are we
he said he's very fortunate we are we are very fortunate that we get to spend time with these incredible
people yeah we're we're we're very fortunate a lot of ways and and and that is a really a big one
and uh we're put it this way we're not very hard done by by by oh hardened
Done by.
受到折磨。受虐待。受到折磨。Smartless。
Hard done,
done by.
Hard done by.
We're done by.
We're done.
Bye.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic
Smartless 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和本·巴尔比科100%有机手工打造的。Smartless。
and artisanly handcrafted by
Michael Grant Terry,
Rob Armjav,
and Bennett Barbico.
Smartless.
并且由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆贾夫和本内特·巴比科精心手工制作。Smartless。